lo que hemos dibujado aquí son 5
triángulos diferentes y lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es encontrar cuáles
de estos triángulos son congruentes
entre sí para esto vamos a escribir aquí
nuestras reglas de congruencia sabemos
que un triángulo es congruente si sus
tres lados son iguales lado lado lado
también si un ángulo entre dos lados
iguales es congruente lado ángulo lado
otro postulado de congruencia nos dice
que si tenemos dos triángulos donde
tenemos un ángulo y luego el otro ángulo
y otro lado en medio iguales tenemos
triángulos congruentes y finalmente si
tenemos dos triángulos que tienen un
ángulo luego otro ángulo y luego un lado
que sean iguales también van a ser
congruentes ahora revisemos estos
triángulos de aquí para encontrar cuáles
son congruentes entre sí veamos este
primer triángulo de acá que es a b y c
aquí nos están dando este lado que es
junto tenemos un ángulo de 60 grados y
en este lado tenemos un ángulo de 40
grados y para que algo sea congruente
con este triángulo tenemos que tener un
ángulo ángulo lado da 2 y aquí no puede
ser cualquier ángulo ángulo lado tienen
que tener el mismo orden si aquí tenemos
el ángulo 40 luego 60 y el lado 7 un
triángulo congruente con este deberá
tener estos elementos en el mismo orden
un ángulo de 40 después un ángulo de 60
y un lado de 7 estos elementos no pueden
estar en distinto orden ahora vamos a
ver cuáles de éstos pueden ser
congruentes con este primer triángulo
que tengan un ángulo de 40 91 de 60 y un
lado de 7 veamos este de acá de
efe vemos que tiene el 7 entre los dos
ángulos 40 y 60 así que éste no parece
que vaya a ser congruente y este de aquí
vemos que tiene ángulo lado ángulo y
puede que sea congruente con el que
acabamos de ver pero no con el que
estamos analizando
aquí en este otro vemos que tenemos un
ángulo de 60 uno de 40 y un lado de 7
así que tenemos un ángulo otro ángulo y
el lado pero el orden de los ángulos no
es el mismo con el que estamos
analizándolo y ya vimos que no pueden
estar en cualquier orden tienen que
tener el mismo orden los ángulos y el
lado aquí vemos que el lado de 7 tiene
el ángulo de 40 grados en lugar de tener
el ángulo de 60 finalmente vemos que
este tenemos el ángulo de 40 un ángulo
de 60 y el lado de 7 este sí se ve
prometedor tenemos que este lado de 7 es
congruente con este otro lado nuestro
ángulo de 60 está junto al lado de 7 que
también es congruente aquí aunque esto
no es obvio ya que están volteado los
triángulos y de nuevo ustedes no asuman
nada simplemente viendo el dibujo de
algo aquí tenemos este ángulo de 40
grados que es congruente con este otro
ángulo de acá y vemos que estos dos
triángulos si son congruentes muy bien
ahora vamos a escribir esto por acá yo
aquí puedo escribir que el triángulo
ce es congruente con el triángulo y aquí
tengo que tener cuidado en el orden en
el que pongo los vértices por ejemplo si
aquí estoy indicando o en este otro
comencé por el vértice a que es el que
tiene el ángulo de 60 grados en este
otro triángulo tengo que ver que el
vértice de 60 grados es el m así que
aquí voy a escribir n
luego pasamos del ángulo a al d y en
este caso b no tiene un ángulo escrito
pero lo podemos calcular 40 60 son 100
para 180 serían 80 el ángulo b vale 80
en ese triángulo el vértice
correspondiente es el m el que no tiene
etiqueta y que está aquí del otro lado
de la línea 7 así que vamos a tener n m
loops perdón m y aquí podemos el vértice
siguiente que es y aquí es importante
recordar que tenemos que escribir las
cosas en orden tenemos que poner los
vértices de ambos triángulos en el mismo
orden para mostrar su congruencia en
este caso que el vértice a corresponde
al vértice n de este otro triángulo que
el vértice b corresponde al vértice m en
este otro y lo mismo que el vértice c
corresponde al vértice o en este otro
triángulo y podemos decir que estos dos
son congruentes por su ángulo ángulo
lado
así que este triángulo es congruente con
este otro triángulo
ahora analicemos este otro triángulo
vemos que tenemos un ángulo de 40 un
lado de 7 y un ángulo de 60 así que aquí
parece que vamos a tener un ángulo al
lado ángulo y vemos el triángulo que
está aquí junto y vemos que tenemos un
ángulo un lado y un ángulo y tenemos que
es 60 grados el ángulo el lado de 7 el
otro ángulo de 40 aunque parezca que no
tienen el mismo orden realmente este
triángulo está volteado
así que es congruente así que vamos a
escribir esto en orden vamos a
identificar que aquí está el ángulo de
60 grados y corresponde a este otro
ángulo de 60 grados vemos que este lado
de 7 es congruente con este otro lado de
7 y finalmente vemos que este ángulo de
40 grados es congruente con este otro de
40 así que vamos a proceder a escribir
vamos a ponerlo de este otro lado y
vamos a escribir que el triángulo d
d efe es congruente con el triángulo
veamos aquí los vértices vemos que aquí
d es el vértice del ángulo de 60 grados
que corresponde con el ángulo perdón con
el vértice h de de ese lado 7 de aquí
vemos que el vértice que corresponde con
este segmento es el vértice g así que
aquí escribimos hg hg
y escribimos que son congruentes por
ángulo lado ángulo así que este
triángulo es congruente con este otro
triángulo de acá y bueno vemos que este
último finalmente no fue congruente con
ninguno de los otros se quedó solito
aunque podríamos sentirnos inclinados en
tratar de ponerlo congruente con este
otro de acá ya que aquí tenemos abajo
estos dos ángulos y el lado de 7 pero
recordemos que el orden aquí es
importante y no podemos poner diferentes
ángulos en diferente orden aquí el
ángulo que tenemos junto al 7 es de 60
grados y en este otro es de 40 por lo
que no es lo mismo y quizás esto nos
pudiera quedar un poco más claro si
escribimos aquí el ángulo que nos falta
en todos estos casos que es un ángulo de
80 grados 60 más 40 son 100 para 180 son
80 80 grados 80 grados 80 grados si éste
hubiera salido un ángulo de 40 o 60
grados podría haber sido un poco más
interesante ya que probablemente
hubiéramos encontrado algunos otros
pares congruentes pero nos quedó un
ángulo de 8
a grados en todos los casos aquí 80
grados desafortunadamente para él ya que
no puedo encontrar un compañero
congruente